The wrong dose of a drug can either have no effect
at all, or it could possibly have dire consequences for an individual.
>> At least I know I have a functioning
ADH, but I'm going to stick to water for now.
>> Variation and mutation in individual genes
that are involved in pathways of drug
metabolism will determine the effectiveness and toxicity
of an individual drug for an individual person.
>> Well, but what about the rest of the family?
>> You mean like how did they respond to drugs?
>> No, I mean
how are we all connected?
>> that's next.
>> Oh, good.
>> It's time we turn our focus to how our genomes connect all of us together.
In the next lesson, we're going to learn all
about human ancestry and evolution using personal genetic information.